well honestly I started definitely with
it as a novel I started right after I
finished a book of short stories
personal velocity and and I had a
publisher and I knew it was gonna be
published and so immediately I started
on this novel but what happened was
because personal ASSA tea when it came
out and I had not made a film for quite
a long time because I couldn't get any
money for a long time and personal
blasting away came out of the shore
service I gave up making films started
to write short stories and decided to
write fiction and then was offered to
make person velocity made it it had some
success and then all of a sudden I was
able to make this film that I had wanted
to make for 10 years which was The
Ballad of Jack and Rose and so I got a
chance to make it and I made that film
well first I made person velocity and
then I made that film so that really
took me away from the novel for a long
time and after I was done with the
second film I was so shattered kind of
that I didn't have it in me to write a
novel a novel you have to be very robust
in yourself you have to have really good
mental health and really good you know
just health I think and I didn't have I
just didn't have the concentration so I
started to try and write it as a
screenplay and I and I got absolutely
nowhere it was a disaster actually so I
thought no case not a film it's
definitely a book and I went back and
then we were in Ireland and I just
started to write and I and so it took me
about two and a half years and I just
wrote the book and then about three
quarters of the way through writing the
book I started to see double like this
certain way that I have where like I
start to see it double like I start
seeing it film two and once I once that
happened it was really the book was
really finished fundamentally finished
but I was starting to kind of add things
on and pad things and take things away
and that's when I already knew so then I
had it more or less finished and I wrote
the screenplay and then I went back and
I finished the novel and sort of at the
very end they started kind of talking to
each other a little bit but I find them
for me the best thing is if I'm gonna do
it like I do that with personal velocity
to that I it's better if I'm not
finished I'm almost finished with the
book but it's still kind of open like
the wound is open and then it's almost
becomes like part of the same thing I
don't know what it would be like to
write a book and then 10 years later
make a movie I don't know what that
would I don't that hasn't been how I've
done it ever
it's really it's interesting I don't I
mean I sort of feel that PIPA in the
book he's always gonna be pepper in the
book like that PIPA will never be erased
or substituted by anything else although
I think that for that what's so for me
and I'm not really I don't think of it
almost like it's not really adapting the
book as much as kind of almost
reinventing it from the same nub and the
same idea because the film is actually
completely different form than the book
but I think that Robin Wright Penn who's
playing PIPA actually kind of she she
gets this essence of PIPA like what I
was saying before about this essence she
really does embody a certain kind of
sort of a annek an acceptance that PIPA
has of other people and the world around
her and a kind of grace but she has
that's very you know that that that was
really beautiful to see and I love
working with actors I love actually in a
funny way losing control because then to
me what you know what the good ones do
is so miraculous they kind of take it
they they it's just exciting to see them
I don't know chant you know make it
something else and yet it's still the
thing you made and yet it's it's me it's
more than what you made and different
than what you made
yeah it's very interesting and I think
it always remains I think the thing that
keeps me hooked into that process is the
alchemical almost an alchemy that
happens inside of the actor and
you know in the end it's it's mysterious
I mean directing is a very mysterious
process because you have to kind of you
don't even really know how you do it I
don't think you have you have to
influence they almost like the magnetic
the magnetic filings of somebody's in
insides you know in a way that isn't you
don't say it you don't like come out and
say what it is and sometimes you don't
know exactly you know you don't know
exactly the result that you would like
but you have a sense of changing
direction and so it's kind of it's it's
kind of magic in a way I guess I feel
like the whole process has an element of
magic to it in a different way than
writing which has it's completely
different satisfaction just as profound
but different